[Music]
I am NOT a stranger to the DA hideaway
they say because we don't want you
promised you I promised you a life of
magic and Wonder
look at those two girls I have
everything I want right here if you
could dream something up what would it
be
lion large giant ten feet tall imagine a
place where people can see things have
never seen before this venture is rather
bizarre they are fascinated by the
unusual and the McCobb okay may I
present the famous Irish giant I'm not
Irish we'll work on the accident
they're just gonna laugh at us laughing
at us anyway might as well get paid
would not ever be enough for you this
isn't about me
[Applause]
[Music]
don't listen to now they don't
understand yet but they will
[Music]
you're putting folks of all kinds
onstage presenting them as equals
we have more protesters every day
you're risking everything you've built
how do you think I've built it you don't
need the whole world to love you just a
few good people have you no shame
father the world is changing and it
refused to be a part of yours you gave
us real family
and whatever made a difference by being
like everyone else
[Applause]
you